I hear now is part two of my exclusive
interview with the first lady Melania
Trump and I asked her about the media's
attacks even on her own son Baron talk
about the me to movement and much more
about the media and had been a lot of
controversy because he says it's fake
news or some of it's fake news
do you agree some of it some of it it's
fake news I would say don't believe
everything what you hear and what you
read not all of it but some of it it's
fake news
even your young son has been brought
into this at times that doesn't that
wouldn't make me angry does that make
you angry it does make me angry because
children should be off-limits and I
protect him and I want to give him
normal life as possible this is not
normal life but I like to protect him
and give him the childhood that he
deserves you feel it's working out as
best he can I've met him he seems like a
young very respectful happy kids he's
very happy he's strong he's tough he's
enjoying life in Washington who's he
more like the fighter the outward
fighter Donald or his mom he has both
qualities he's a fighter
he's a fighter he is a soft beautiful
heart but he's a fighter too and he's
very strong do you find with all the
issues that your husband deals with
foreign policy
Russia China little raka been used his
term all the issues with employment
regulation energy borders the wall you
mostly an agreement on the big issues
that he fights for every day which
policies are some of them the I agree
Sam I don't and I give him my opinion
but he's the president he was elected so
when all is said and done and you now
have taken a more public role what do
you want people to know about what
issues matter to you the most I know you
have your be best campaign you've seen
the military you're traveling the world
now more than you have what do you want
people to know about what's important to
you that's personal ad well might be
best thing you should have it's in early
stages and I'm very proud what I
accomplished so far and I have a three
pillars that it's focusing on its
well-being of children opioid crisis and
social media use so I travel the country
I meet with the people I meet with the
parents and I want to shine a spotlight
on the organization and programs that
support children and want to be the best
for them
to grow up in responsible adults on
borders in particularly did go down to
the border and you met with a lot of
Border Patrol guys I've been down there
13 times in my 23 years of Fox
everywhere from the Rio Grande to San
Diego in drug warehouses when you're
down there and you see with your own
eyes what's going on is the wall in your
head the only answer I think we need the
wall to protect the country the security
the security to protect it from the
drugs of course we know we will always
have people coming over but this is one
solution that we could stop a big
caravans coming over and I was in the
ball at the border and so first hand
and met with Border Patrol and I see
what they do 24/7 and their hands are
full we saw rocks and bottles being
pelted at them and they tried to crash
the border like the southern border of
Mexico you recently spoke out about the
me to movement we saw what happened with
justice Cavanaugh in his confirmation
hearing which
to me is so over-the-top but you also
said yes we should take it seriously
listen to women but then you've talked
about due process and the presumption of
innocence do you feel that's missing in
this movement I think we should all be
heard women and men we need to be heard
and we need to be treated equal remember
every time before we ever heard from
some of the individuals within the
Justice Kavanagh case you hear people
say I believe we hadn't heard from
anybody you can't believe till they're
proven guilty
it cannot be guilty to the proven guilty
and that's very important that we follow
the law I want to talk about your
journey a little more because we kind of
glossed over it because you grew up in a
small town in Slovenia then you're a
model and Milan and the Paris you were
independent you were alone at that time
correct how did you grow up wanting to
be a model or I study design in
architecture and stopped my study
architecture
because I wanted to go in modeling
business and professional career as a
model so I moved to Milan and Paris and
I was I start modeling in Sylvania first
when I was 16 and then when we went to
Milan and then starts from there were
you with your parents so you go up fast
at a young age independent yes as you
look back on that and then your journey
from Paris and Milan to New York did
that make you the person that says that
they are confident a good friend and
true to herself yes my journey made me
that madam first lady thank you so much